Threat going on at the same time.
I want to bring you back to something you said earlier that you sort of glossed
over,
but you were talking about quantum physicists,
right?
Getting everything wrong.
So I flew to Moscow.
No,
and I've debunked that.
And a book called the God problem.
How I godless cosmos creates that has five Harris's and heresy.
Number one is that one,
is that a a does not equal a,
that's Aristotle's primary law of identity.
No,
it's not always true.
Um,
one of the laws is the theory of entropy is so fucking wrong.
Entering means that all everything is falling apart constantly.
And that in order to make something positive happen,
you have to shed more negative energy,
not really negative energy,
more dispersed,
waste energy.
And in fact the universe doesn't work like that.
The universe in the very beginning at formed quarks from,
from nothing but motion quarks for emotion.
Are you kidding me?
Yeah.
The first things from movement,
are you joshing?
No.
And then the quarks had to get together in groups of three because this is a
profoundly social universal,
they couldn't survive.
And one form of Cork like this with one up and two down or something like that
is a neutron and the other direction,
three quarks is a proton and all of this is anti entropic.
And then what do all of these billiard balls do?
What are all these particles do?
380,000 years later,
they begin sweet themselves together in these massive social agglomerations that
look like big potatoes and those are the beginnings of galaxies before they form
their spiral arms and stuff like that.
Uh,
and then within the,
the spiral arms of these galaxies,
gravity balls are competing with each other to see who's the biggest gravity
ball and the biggest wins and what does he do to the losers?
He swallows them and gets even bigger,
which makes it possible for that gravity ball to confront another bunch of
gravity balls and beat them out for size and swallow them.
Eventually what happens is you get so much gravity and so much matter in this
gravity ball that the gravity ball explodes.
That's called a son a star.
And around it are smaller gravity balls that managed to hold their own in
competitions and their planets and moons.
How the hell do you go?
Even this short distance into the life of galaxy that's been around for 13.7
billion years with precisely the opposite of entropy happening.
What is the official definition of venture be?
How's it defined by Webster's dictionary?
Do you know?
It's usually a weasel definition weasel.
Yeah.
In other words,
it's deliberately obscure.
Ah,
because it's such a weird subject.
Yeah.
Um,
that's funny.
But every priesthood has a shibboleth.
A shibboleth is a magic word.
If you can't pronounce it,
you're dead.
Ah.
And so every tribe wants you to believe in something that's impossible.
Remember,
red queen or the White Queen in Alice in Wonderland said,
sometimes I dream up six impossible things before breakfast.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And you have to pass the test by showing that you believe in something that's
obviously fatuously wrong.
And that's the,
and the Shibboleth for being considered a legitimate scientist is preaching
allegiance to pledging allegiance to entropy.
Pull it up.
Let me see what it says here.
It says a,
a measure of the unavailable energy and a closed thermodynamic system that is
also usually considered to be a measure of the systems disorder that is a
property of this system state.
And that varies directly with any reversible change in heat in the system and
inversely with the temperature of the system broadly,
the degree of disorder or uncertainty in the system.
So that's what they're saying is the degree of disorder or uncertainty in the
system.
Obviously that's a very lucid explanation and you could recite it to a five year
old and need to understand exactly what you were saying or too easily.
It is a little reason.
It's very weasley.
It has lots of outs.
So my book,
the God problem,
how a godless cosmos creates debunks that along with a bunch of other
assumptions and current side is that assumption exists.
He believed because in the 19th century when this was formulated,
um,
the metaphor of the day was the steam engine.
It was the hot new technology.
It was to the 19th century,
what computers are due,
the 22nd century or whatever we're living in now.
Uh,
the 21st century,
sorry.
And um,
so what they realized was you take this steam and you push it into a piston and
it throws that piston up into the air and then the piston comes back down again
but then there's waste.
The steam then has lost its energy and it comes out of an exhaust valve and you
put in more hot steam.
Right.
Um,
so this was a theory about the waste that comes out of the steam engine.
But now that we don't have,
I mean cars,
yes,
they produce exhaust.
Now would you say that um,
solar power and solar power does not produce exhaust.
So where's the entropy?
Right,
but where's the entropy?
Let's story of the universe.
I was telling you aggregation of the batteries because I mean they are all yes
that that could be but it's a,
it's a square edge compared to the construction of a song.
It's a squid compared to the construction of a galaxy and all that random stuff
in the universe.
All those random particles,
first of all they're not random.
They all participate in something.
The universe rings like a Gong and its early days.
It has pressure waves.
That means that these elementary particles are scooching together and forming a
wave.
Is that a technical term?
Yes.
And then they're squinching apart and they're forming a trough and then there
are scorching together again.
And that wave ripples across the cosmos.
The way that you see waves rippling across the Pacific when you're flying to
Hawaii,
um,
is that entropic,
is that disorder constantly increasing?
Now it's the very opposite.
What the universe stars.
It takes every form of waste and turns it into an opportunity.
It,
I mean what we call this place earth,
what are we naming it for?
The Excreta of warms the shit of worms because they produced what we call soil.
Well think of the meaning of that word.
Soil.
When something is soiled,
what does it like?
It's not covered with earthy loam.
It's dirty.
Um,
so,
and we call it dirt when it's in the earth.
So we are taking this and tropic stuff,
the shit that came out of worms and we're farming in it and plants are growing
and it trees are growing in it.
Flowers are growing in it.
Is that entropy,
is that a continual slide toward disorder?
It's the very opposite.
It's a continual slide toward order and higher degrees of form.
How is this theory been received?
Um,
well,
uh,
or your interpretation of it?
That's a good question because,
um,
I really have no answer.
Um,
the people who I sent the book to in the early days,
all of them except well including a Nobel prize winner and I think three
MacArthur genius award winners all said this is a great book and one compared it
to have Charles Lyles history of the earth,
which gave Darwin a lot of ideas and to Darwin's origin of the species and
asked,
is this really a great book?
Like those two books?
And the answer has been,
yes,
this is the Lucifer principle.
No,
this is the God problem who I,
godless cosmos creates.